ouah florian philippot président des
patriotes et conseiller régional grand
test
[Musique]
bonjour florian philippot bonne année à
vous merci d'être en direct avec nous ce
matin sur rtl france alors on va vous
demander évidemment une première
réaction à ce qui se passe aux etats
unis ce matin qui se passe aux etats
unis c'est à mon avis y monter
l'explosion de plusieurs années de
frustration de mépris d'humiliations
alors ce qui s'est passé je crois que
donald trump lui même ne le souhaitez
pas et de l'a10 un qu'on s'entende bien
mais que venir simplement de les leçons
de morale manifestants sans essayer de
comprendre pourquoi ça s'est produit à
le faire croire qu'il a simplement le
bien contre le mal
en l'occurrence c'est assez idiot ce
président américain a été élu il ya
quatre ans le pendant quatre ans chaque
jour tout ce qu'il a pu faire a été
moquée a été brocardée a été attaquée
parce qu'il menait en a été une
politique qui ne correspondaient pas à
vous intégrer une certaine oligarchie
que ce soit le protectionnisme
économique que ce soit la politique de
la paix au niveau international que ce
soit la politique de lutte contre les
grands lobbys big tech comme il dit où
les lobbys pharmaceutiques
or il a été maltraité et les suspicions
de fraudes un peu cerise sur le gâteau
lors des dernières élections n'ont pas
été traitée sérieusement
elles n'ont pas été étudiées
sérieusement donc on a accumulé comme
une cocotte-minute s'ils voulaient
beaucoup de 2,2 le colère de sentiment
de mépris d'humiliations dans une grosse
partie de la population américaine
puisqu'il a quand même recueilli 74
millions de voix et sa pro fini par
produire des réactions à coin
incontrôlable je crois qu'il faut faire
une analyse politique sinon on ne
comprend absolument pas alors il ya eu
une condamnation unanime de certains
chefs d'état occidentaux dont allo
président français qui a même publié une
vidéo à 3 heures du matin je crois
justement pour condamner son coup de
force écouter quand dans une des plus
vieilles démocraties du monde
des partisans d'un président sortant
remettent en cause par les armes
les résultats légitimes d'une élection
c'est une idée universelle celle d'un
homme une voix qui est battue en brèche
est ce qu'il ne va pas un peu vite
emmanuel macron à un coup de force par
les armes ça reste à prouver
on sait qu'une femme est morte mais sous
les balles de policiers donc le coup de
force par les armes mais pas forcément
prouver pour l'instant oui mais il est
complètement ridicule emmanuel macron
avec en mettant le drapeau américain
derrière lui enfin ce sera au parlement
son rêve puisque la france et il a un
profond mépris on sait bien tout ça est
complètement grotesque et ridicule et
emmanuel macron n'a pas de leçons sur
les démocraties a donné hier on vient
encore de nous dire qu'on reprenait pour
six mois + 6 mois de mesures
transitoires d'état d'urgence sanitaire
on est dans un pays on n'a plus aucune
liberté ni liberté individuelle on a
l'intention de prolonger effectivement
et on va parler de la situation en
france tout de suite avec vous ferions
philippot puisqu'à cette polémique
algérien sur la stratégie de vaccination
et les présidents de région aujourd'hui
veulent faire cavalier seul et commander
eux mêmes les vaccins sont passés par
l'europe c'est votre point de vue vous
êtes vous conseiller régional du grand
est est ce que c'est votre avis non moi
je pense qu'il faut si vous voulez une
stratégie nationale
le problème c'est que depuis le départ
on s'est enfermés dans le couple
confinement vaccin ou même pas vaccin
si le premier c'est plutôt de la
thérapie génique on a fait croire aux
français qu'il y avait pas d'autres
horizons
c'est dire qu'on a mis je crois que
c'est une première dans l'histoire de la
médecine pour refasse une maladie on a
mis de côté tout ce qui était prévention
tout ce qui était traitement alors qu'il
ya même des pistes extrêmement
prometteuse efficace qui ont été relevés
ces derniers temps donné par image dans
l'article hier 6 ou avant-hier sur les
données concernant l'ivermectine par
exemple mais ça on n'en parle pas a
probablement parce que ça rapporte un
sou et on nous enferme dans ce couple et
en plus il gère très mal
ils ont décidé que les vaccins c'est ce
que je dirai par l'union européenne et
alors là il faut lire la presse
allemande a écouté les politiques
également pour savoir pour comprendre le
pot-aux-roses
en fait l'union européenne a géré ça
n'importe comment les résultats et bien
ça se passe très mal plus loin de ce que
touche assez pas que quelque chose est
touché par l'union européenne
généralement ça se transforme en boue
voilà donc c'est un peu ce qui se passe
ce que ça a un petit toit yable on
en train de tuer notre pays on est en
train d'entretenir le psychodrame des
vaccins alors que nous pourrions nous
inspirer de ce qui marche notamment en
extrême orient où les pays qui sont
beaucoup plus qu'ils abordent ces crises
de manière beaucoup plus sereine ont
décidé de laisser leur liberté aux
acteurs économiques et aux gens mais en
même temps de prendre en charge des
malades de les traiter ce que nous ne
faisons pas dans notre pays et ce que je
ne comprends pas alors effectivement le
patron français du laboratoire moderna a
tiré à boulets rouges sur la stratégie
européenne le vaccin moderna qui a été
validé justement hier par l'europe
il met en cause la lenteur des commandes
et le tropisme européen et goûter entre
juin et août il ne s'est rien passé
les discussions ont repris à la fin de
l'été et le contrat a été signé fin
novembre
pour vous donner une idée au canada
entre les deux premières réunions
scientifique et médicale et la signature
du contrat cet été il s'est écoulé deux
semaines voilà cette lenteur au niveau
français pourrait s'expliquer vous
disiez 1 par cette lenteur au niveau
européen ah oui non mais alors là si
vous voulez tous les to les vaccinaux
lattre ferait mieux de s'en prendre au
gouvernement français qui a transféré
cette responsabilité à l'union
européenne et qui fait n'importe quoi
l'union est le 17 novembre
elle a acheté 405 millions de doses a
cure au bac alors même que à ce moment
là cette entreprise allemande de vaccins
n'étaient même pas encore en phase iii
sur son propre vaccin est d'ailleurs
toujours pas sorti mais elle en a acheté
405 millions de doses sûrement pour
faire plaisir à madame merkel pas tout
ça est absolument idéologique c'est
n'importe quoi c'est mal gellet et et
résultats passés le psychodrame
entretenu et au lieu de se tourner
encore une fois vers le traitement vers
d'autres solutions qui permettraient
d'éviter de tuer notre pays
hello liberté eh bien l'on s'enferme
dans cette stratégie confinement
confinement restrictions vaccins et on
fait peur à tout le monde et on nous dit
que c'est l'état d'urgence pour un an
etc
je suis je commence à être catastrophé
par ce qui se passe dans notre pays
j'appelle vraiment aussi bien les
professions comme les restaurateurs la
culture et les commerçants et tous les
français en général à se remuer à se
bouger
parce que là ils sont en train d'être le
dévorer à feu doux par ce qui se passe
merci florian philippot d'avoir répondu
ce matin en direct à nos questions sur
arte france confinement ou pas on le
verra évidemment ce soir avec les
annonces de jean castex prévu à 18h
merci